what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich for us
let's just trying to get a lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent pelina evil marinova
i don't know why she's drinking coffee
that's fine but
now block five is the sponsor of lunch
money go get a block by account 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account it's
awesome you'll like it i like it
everyone likes i'm an investor i sit on
the board
go earn eight point six percent apy in
their interest bearing account go to
block five dot com
slash pomp what's up first topic let's
go
um okay wait so um first of all before
we start i want to give a shout out to
mike that we met on the streets of new
york
from verizon he is a lunch money viewer
shout out mike
we're walking down the street and all of
a sudden he goes yo
lunch money i was like what's up mike he
goes not much
he's a bitcoiner his kids are bitcoiners
he's a lunch money fan
i'm a fan yeah all right topics let's go
okay i'll tell you later um so first of
all the election we haven't seen you
guys since friday
the media called it um it is joe biden
as the 46th president of the united
states
do you have something to say about it
because then i have something else
well i don't think anyone's the
president yet the
electoral college hasn't called it the
media has called it yes
uh they have been right every single
time when they all agree on it
uh the one kind of variable in this
situation
is we've never had a president who
doesn't want to
concede uh and so my general view of
this is like look
president trump in the current
administration they've got a whole bunch
of legal
uh avenues that they could pursue go
presume sure that's your right knock
yourself out
uh the courts will decide if there's any
thing wrong or any issues or whatever if
the courts decide that then the courts
decide that there was problems the
courts say there were no problems and
there were no problems but like
that's part of a democracy is that you
have certain rights and you've got to
pursue knock yourself out
at the same time uh as of right now uh
joe biden and
kamala harris are the president-elect
and vice president-elect
and i think the world's gonna continue
to operate under that
assumption uh unless something changes
now
one other thing i'm gonna say uh which i
think is really really important and
i think that what we're going to
discover is that this is going to become
more of a topic
in the future uh in the next couple of
weeks if you believe
that in every single election at the
local state and federal level there is
100 accuracy ever in history
you're crazy you're absolutely nuts
right when you're processing
millions tens of millions in the uh
presidential election 100 plus million
votes there are going to be inaccuracies
there's going to be issues especially
when you have people sitting there
literally sometimes physically counting
pieces of paper right
it's just it's impossible the question
is going to
arise though right both parties
if they wanted to would be able to show
that there are
dead people voting and all this kind of
crazy stuff right
but that doesn't mean necessarily that
it was malicious
that it was rigged or that it changed
the votes
or changed who the winner is and so i
think that what we're about to
forgo into is this very very nuanced
conversation
where people are going to have to get
comfortable understanding
that there are issues obstacles and
inaccuracies when you have a human
driven process right you're literally
counting
millions and millions and millions of
things and you have humans doing it in
some cases and so there's going to be
issues
the big question is just going to be was
any of this malicious
and also does it affect the outcome and
i think that's what the courts are going
to have to decide
and it's going to get real weird real
quick and
i think that my number one piece of
advice to people is just wait till we
have all the facts
like i don't i don't know i have no clue
let's wait till we have facts and then
we can decide
i have two thoughts okay one how is it
possible that no startup technology
company has not partnered with the
government and try to figure this
out because the fact that they are
humans sitting there trying to decipher
what the other human tried to vote as is
ridiculous
second of all yes everybody's making
this out to be a huge massive deal that
it wasn't called immediately
this happened in 2000 and it happened in
a very very big way
they went to core all this stuff there
was fight al gore didn't concede
immediately
so i mean if we i think i saw a meme
that was like if we had social media in
2000 it would have been
wild same like the people growing up now
thinks that
think that this is outside of the norm
it's not it's happened before
so yeah and what to your point on this
in 2000
remember there's literally like videos
of it if you go back and look at the old
uh news they have people looking at
pieces of paper like this
and they're trying to figure out which
hole you punched
and the the chad the piece of paper
that didn't get fully done i mean it's
not that like that
literally helped derive who the
president of the united states was who
by the way
ended up being president for eight years
and we went to two wars under that
president
right so again it's like let's make sure
we get it right and
before everyone freaks out i'm not
saying that
what the media has called is inaccurate
what i'm saying
is that is a really important step
towards us
getting to a place where every american
says
this is the president let's move forward
good
here is my next point on this um there
was a man
who bet on betfair um in the uk i
believe
um he he bet 1.3 million dollars on joe
biden to win the presidency but he can't
get his money yet
until it's officially called
and who imagine knowing you got 1.3
million but not being able to get at
what
yeah he made 710 000 in profit on a 1.3
million dollar bet
that's pretty good i mean look at at the
end of the day my whole point with this
is just that
uh we are watching democracy and the
checks and balances
of the united states play out and
rather than everyone be so divisive and
freaking out and like ready to like
literally like beat each other up
like everyone chill out let the process
play out
i promise that that is what makes
america great
let's just let it play out and
ultimately
the courts are going to decide and the
electoral college don't you think there
should be better technology like maybe
instead of making course
razors and mattresses like go make some
voting technology
there's plenty of companies that claim
that they can help solve this problem
the big thing is
how the politicians i mean remember look
at the debate
around mail-in balance right and like
just the debate of like should we let
people mail something in or not
was so heavily contested and became so
controversial and so politicized
that when you get into things like
technology everyone freaks out and no
one can agree
if amazon can scan my face and know it's
me buying something in their
store i think we can figure out of
course
of course and part of it becomes then
what do you say to people about like
oh okay um paulina you want to vote but
you don't have a smartphone
then is there like voter suppression and
like those are the issues that come up
so again it's like i actually love that
the process is playing out the way that
it is because this is what makes america
the best country in the world the most
democratic country in the world
and just everyone chill
out and just wait for the process
so far joe biden is the pre is the
president-elect kamala harris is the
vice president-elect
let's go also final final thing on this
topic um
i read a profile uh recently i believe
it was in the new york times
about russia there was a ma like a race
for a
mayor of this town but because everybody
knows it's rigged
usually they try to make it look
democratic by having
somebody else to run against but this
guy he couldn't find anybody else to run
against and nobody wanted to do it
and so he got this woman who was
i think she was like a janitor um
and she ran and she actually won
so then it wasn't rigged it was actually
somewhat democratic well
he was pissed okay um all right
next so uh pfizer and
bio and tech have announced monday their
coronavirus vaccine
was more than 90 effective in preventing
covid19 among those without
evidence of prior infection hailing the
development is a great day for science
and humanity
i don't want to have to go down this
path but what i am going to say
is that coronavirus
corona virus has been politicized
it's real obviously there's a lot of
people who've gotten sick
there's a lot of people who have died it
should be taken
very seriously we should do the things
necessary to protect people
and to make sure that the most
vulnerable folks in our society those
pre-existing conditions the elderly
elderly etc
are protected at the same time
the level of hypocrisy and
politicization
of this is appalling
earlier uh this past weekend there was a
reporter at
vox who within a 12-hour span he took a
picture of everyone celebrating the
political election
and he tweeted it and said basically
like look at all these amazing people
celebrating democracy
congratulations to everyone and they
were all there was a bunch of people
packed into an area outside the white
house
within 12 hours he tweeted again at the
end of the notre dame football game
everyone rushed the field
and he said these basically you know
something to the effect of like these
irresponsible kids
uh need to take it seriously students
are being blamed i don't think we should
be blaming the students
i think they're actually taking it very
seriously and so the point ends up being
by the way either crowds are bad or
crowds aren't bad
and both of them they had masks on there
was no social distancing
i don't care which side you come out on
i'm not a scientist but if scientists
say hey you shouldn't do that
then you should apply it equally to
everybody if scientists say that's fine
as long as everyone has a mask on cool
then knock yourselves out go do whatever
you want
but this whole idea of like oh crowds
are
bad uh unless it's for political reasons
like no that's not how science works
right so like don't tell people to look
at the science and then go do dumb [ __ ]
like that that's true all right
so that's one two it is
very interesting the fact that i had a
friend
on uh saturday say to me he was joking
but he was like oh joe biden one
coronavirus is over he was kidding right
he was he was basically saying like
pay attention to what happens well not
so kidding
we now see cnn who had
literally for eight months cnn had a
death scoreboard on their screen every
second of the day
they had a scoreboard how many people
had gotten the case how many people had
died all stuff and they were just
and they were just racking it up racking
it up racking it up like a like a
sports scoreboard after the presidential
election it's gone
is it over no so why are we now changing
the way that we covered
it why are we not fear-mongering as much
anymore
again some people may say there's other
things they have to do maybe it's a
coincidence
or maybe it's not but you're gonna start
to see people asking questions now
now the idea that this morning there's
this vaccine announced right it's 90
effective which is very very high it's
much more effective than i'll say the
flu vaccine or anything like that
we still don't know certain details like
how uh effective is it for like the
elderly or certain subset populations
we also don't know what some of the side
effects are so they're not ready to
distribute it yet we saw some science to
go
this is very very encouraging uh and
then we gotta figure out how to
distribute this thing
but what becomes very interesting is
we heard over and over and over again
how
bad this was mismanaged and all this
stuff and now we're looking we're saying
wait a second
this is record time for the development
of a vaccine
and it's announced the monday after the
election
again i i don't know what's going on
like i'm literally at the point now
where i don't know what to believe i
don't understand
how some of this stuff has been
politicized you just start to
look at yourself and say you know what
this all tells me ultimately
you are responsible for you it goes back
to personal responsibility
right there should be a vaccine i hope
that they come up with it i'm not gonna
be the one to invent the vaccine i'm not
going to be the one to approve the
vaccine and i'm not going to be the one
to distribute the vaccine
i can only control the things in my life
and right now
i anything related to coronavirus or the
vaccine
i have no control over and so at some
point you just say look i got to do the
things i got to do to be successful and
happy
and other and everything else the cars
will fall where they fall but i think
that that's what ultimately people are
learning here
is it's all about personal
responsibility stop worrying about
things that you can't control and let's
move on
mcdonald's yes i like your snakeskin
shirt by the way thank you mcdonald's
is doubling down on a trend it saw
succeed
during the pandemic which is comfort
food
and so now it is uh focusing more on its
popular menu items and selling more
chicken demand for the familiar in these
uncertain times is more important than
ever
mcdonald's said in its investor update
adding that it expects core menu items
like the big mac
in quarter pounder burgers chicken
mcnuggets and french fries
to contribute to its growth moving
forward
and expects high dub what is it single
digit growth in 2021
mcdonald's is the best restaurant in
america it's consistent
it's accessible it's low cost and
there's a good variety
it is the best restaurant in america
they are trying to boost their sales by
launching this new
crispy chicken sandwich i wonder how
much of it was driven wasn't it popeye's
had a chicken sandwich last year
that everyone went crazy for there's two
restaurants i think those popeyes and
uh kfc maybe you guys will correct me in
the comments if i'm wrong
um but they basically had this chicken
sandwich everyone's going nuts for
and so mcdonald's trying to get in on
that
virgin hyperloop the super fast train
that goes underground that's supposed to
get you from like la to new york and
i don't even know how very short period
of time
virgin hyperloop gave the first ride on
its test track sunday in las vegas
but it will be years before the public
could potentially take a high-speed ride
on a hyperloop well they just put humans
in the hyperloop yeah which is crazy so
the way it works is there's a tube
and that tube has another tube that's
basically inside of it that people sit
so think of it kind of like if you took
a pvc pipe right
and then you put like a tennis ball
inside the pvc pipe
and the tennis ball can shoot through
the pvc pipe if you like you know
uh push it hard if it ever crashes you
turn into dust basically
no uh and the way the way that the
technology works is it's
done through magnets so the more
friction that there would be between the
inner tube and the outer tube
the slower you would go obviously right
so if you think of like the tire
touching the road
it can only go so fast uh with this by
using magnets they can push you very
quickly
uh and so these humans they went over a
hundred miles an hour
uh anywhere from zero to a a hundred
plus i think like 107 miles an hour
in just over six seconds so and they
didn't go very far there's only like a
500 meter track
right like kind of a testing track but
the fact that the technology works
they're able to get to those types of
speeds that quickly imagine if you could
basically
go from you know new york to la
which is like the farthest that they
would ever build it so you don't think
if it ever crashes the humans
completely die
no because you basically they're gonna
build it in a way that uh if it
crashes the humans don't get hurt inside
going that fast
of course i mean look you can get in a
car accident going 100 miles an hour and
not die
now by the way there are times where
people die so it depends on when but
i'm just saying like it's not
necessarily guaranteed
i read this really interesting article
on hyperloop how it said that
when they were making decisions about
how to design it
at first they were having they had
windows the problem is when you're going
that fast
it triggers people's um like uh you
start getting nauseous when you see
things going that fast so then
they decided not to have anything that
you could see outside but i thought that
was really interesting
and also uh they had trouble with like
turns uh because that could also make
you
extremely nauseous okay
i like this long innovators long
technologists
short the haters moon exploration
startup ispace
not myspace ispace opens new
us office and hires spacex alum to lead
development
of its next lander you're trying to get
away from the light because i'm doing
the same thing yeah the light's trying
to get me someone on my hand can't get
me
uh a japanese startup
it's opening an office in denver and
it's hiring people away from
nasa and spacex i like this why
i'm long everything space space is the
next frontier we're going to get there
when we get to mars
hey we have been to mars no
what human ever wanted okay not human
but like us humans have sent things to
mars
oh yeah yeah we've sent toys up there
they've done some collection
i watched the martian i could make the
plants in the ground
no you couldn't you're making fun of i'm
growing a tomato plant currently and
he's like
why you got to take care of that plant
like that growing
is a oh my god it's growing did you see
the little oh
next next launch you didn't even plant
it you ordered it off the internet
that's not
you're not no but but this is the
millennial version of uh i have
i have a garden no but they send it and
then i have to like
water it and expose it to light and
spray it with water every day
i think and i'm just doing it out of the
kindness of my heart because i think
it's guys
tomorrow i'm going to show you this plan
we're going to take a we're going to
take a vote
okay oh okay some grocery stores are
limiting toilet paper and disinfect and
disinfecting wipe purchases again
guys stop buying all the toilet paper oh
my god
remember it's fine people are hoarding
this does not happen in other countries
take as much as you need and go home i'm
waiting to get a pitch from a toilet
paper
uh startup make toilet paper smooth
again
all right what control paper do you use
soft again i guess right soft yeah what
kind of
toilet paper do you use whichever ones
you buy
exactly and they're soft maybe i should
do a toilet paper roll i do
not just go get a bunch of different
types of toilet paper so
there is no joke today because i think
i've run out of the dad jokes on the
internet
but i have a new segment i actually
haven't
talked to you about it yet but i'm
making the executive decision
we're gonna try it so in the comments
if you say do hashtag i think that yeah
so i can find it easily
ask lm which is ask lunch money
and it can be about money it can be
about the economy
it can be about his weird hair looking
thing right now it can be
anything and then i will choose a
question that we will answer
at the end of a lunch money segment i
like this
oh okay good so what people so people
get asked a question and then we'll
answer it on the show yeah could be
about
the recession about the economy about
hyperloop
toilet paper don't ask me questions
about toilet paper
yeah don't ask them questions about all
right use hashtag asklm
yes does do hashtags work on youtube i
think
okay i don't think so no problem no for
me to find
all right guys go ahead and use the
hashtag ask us questions and we'll do
our best to answer
that's it for today see you guys
tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends